i would thank you all for allowing me to
speak to you tonight but you tried not
to allow it yet here i am now you only
give us 60 seconds so let me get to the
point you are all child abusers you prey
upon impressionable children and
indoctrinate them into your insane
ideological cult a cult which holds many
fanatical views but none so deranged as
the idea that boys or girls and girls
are boys by imposing this vile nonsense
on students to the point even of forcing
young girls to share locker rooms with
boys you deprive these kids of safety
and privacy and something more
fundamental too which is truth if
education is not grounded in truth then
it is worthless worse it is poison you
are poison you are predators i can see
why you try to stop us from speaking you
know that your ideas are indefensible
you silence the opposing side because
you have no argument you can only hide
under your beds like pathetic little
gutless cowards hoping we shut up and go
away but we won't
i promise you that
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you again very very soon